à la salle al bahri salle à l eau est
nommé l'hôtel elle fait qu elle est en
fait toutes les mains
c'est intéressant
elle est à la merci une question estime
augustine je vous explique c'est que
jean-luc il regarde tout ce qui se passe
en dehors des missions
voilà fait tout ce qu'on voit pas nous
il le voit et c'est des téléspectateurs
qui posent des questions sur l'émission
exactement
vous faites la question va bien je sais
pas où il va alors mst par jour je
m'appelle aglaé j'ai regardé l'émission
la semaine dernière et j'ai trouvé qu'il
y avait une bonne ambiance dans l'équipe
après la grande brassera peut-on espérer
un prime la grande baston c'est une
excellente question mais avant d'y la
cour devait faire un truc que je fais
jamais d'avis en fait ça c'était la
deuxième prise d'abyei
je vais vous dire la vérité mais la
première nous a tellement fait rire
ouais et déborah et 35e travail et que
je pouvais pas garder pour moi regarder
alors bonjour je m'appelle aglaé j'ai
regardé l'émission la semaine dernière
et j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait une bonne
ambiance dans l'équipe après la grande
race rapt ont espéré un prime
la droite a payé
ocz et tout et tout près à des tâches
team mais voilà c'est ça ce serait
dommage de gâcher
oxis une bonne qui changerait mais
évidemment non il y aura pas de près de
la grande baston évidemment parfois ça
peut surprendre des débats animés entre
chroniqueurs mais ça a toujours été
comme ça regardez par exemple prendre à
magnéto vous allez voir mathieu agathe
vont avoir une vraie explication mais
dès qu'on va revenir à l'antenne
ils vont faire un grand sourire ça
s'appelle être pro jamais d'habitude ces
deux avec un pourtour
[Applaudissements]
ça s'appelle de la maîtrise est
vieillissant qu'on travaille ensemble
depuis longtemps
jean-michel ils étaient là lors de la
première émission en 2010 à rennes
depuis syrie n'a toujours pas réussi à
s'en débarrasser la croix sur son siège
et comment les mener mais nous la ce
projet il a essayé ouais mais en même
temps avec son ancienneté jean michel
saive permet de prendre un peu de recul
sur l'équipe regarder
[Musique]
mais par contre tu vas tu souhaites
synchrone elle quand même femme
nakaya kia
[Musique]
limoux
[Applaudissements]
mais évidemment il est rare que les
chinois savent nous non pas du quai sur
des tic puisqu'il n'a pas d'éthique j'ai
les origines asiatiques
oui c'est vrai bah bien sûr pas d'une
famille qui a vécu au vietnam
ça ne fait pas de toi ou grand père
s'est remarié avec ce net mng des petits
jeux pas qu'on appelle simplement s'il
ya des enfants dans la famille à la
généalogie la famille a vécu on a deux
chine compterait en temps j'adore l'asie
mais face à aller il avait dit je suis
fier qu'on vous savez moi / minute
ouais bon il a pas de problème est que
les chinois aient la juste un problème
avec moi car je pense que vous êtes au
courant on a parlé tout à l'heure depuis
quelques semaines jean michel investi
dans les cartes de visite de sniper
officiel alors maintenant il faut qu'ils
rentabilisent et comme il n'est pas tout
jeune et qu'il a regardé trop de rester
bruges maurice temps vide n'a forcément
un de trop qui doit disparaître
alors je m'en prends plein la tronche un
par l'antenne et pendant les off
j'ai fait un calcul selon le même
institut qui valide 98 % des
interventions de maxime gainey j'occupe
63% des conversations de jean michel et
de ses complices
[Musique]
philippe lemoine maintenant il va pas
chômer à 17h 16h
[Musique]
pour moi tu es belle saison
la neige
[Musique]
à l'oreille à david affluence qui veut
ravir même la même là dessus mais en
fait je me demande si tous les deux vous
snipe et aussi dans la vraie vie et
éventuellement dans votre vie amoureuse
ou pas
alors lui ça fait longtemps qu'ils
apprennent à écrire et jean luc et
sniper n'était qu'à la télé ou pas non
non je sais tape aussi en amateur
passionné parking de supermarché
mais c'est dans la cour ont posé ces
questions
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'aime bien france que je me sent
fragile avec m je suis curieux et que
j'aime apprendre des plus grands j'ai
essayé de décortiquer une des vannes les
plus brillants de la semaine de jean
michel on revenait sur la réaction de
slimane dans salut les terriens qui
expliquait pourquoi il répondait aux
commentaires haineux sur les réseaux
sociaux en exclusivité dès lors comment
un artisan de la vanne va les chercher
une information pour faire mouche juste
après un petit bijou
changement sinon c'est pas moi les
chansons pour cent de plus
[Musique]
mon sac à dos et font évidemment pas
later sur sur twitter et autres réseaux
sociaux mais hassa à leur décharge c'est
vrai que pendant un an et laly padam
padam en arrive vous ne m'enlèverez ils
sont un peu échauffés quand est-ce qu'il
arrive il était énervé je comprends
qu'il est chez shell va chauffer un peu
ta blague sur ses fans l'attendent avec
son sac à dos les yeux mais j'ai les
pieds sur 7
ça sentait bien
[Musique]
je voulais dire c'est même un peu paumé
sa première chanson ces panneaux mon
arrivée l'aï dit je m'en vais il arrive
où il parle peu plus quoi en plus le
talent avait sorti comme ça et à deux
ans
[Musique]
il arrive quand sur les grands ça me
chercher
qui va là on arrive mieux diront comment
l'échelle comme le soleil qui recycle
evans qui marchent pas ouais vous
remarquerez qu en novembre 2016
il faisait plus vieux quand la bise à
passer il acheter des chevaux des types
d'ailleurs pour acheter des cheveux au
même endroit que jean mouzat des
problèmes parce que voilà vous faites
toujours des couleurs tout ça ça vous va
très bien jean michel lui paraît mais je
vous lis merci non plus que j'ai vu à 3
tentatives 3 bid et entendre quand même
même si je vais être honnête la dernière
fois c'était pas un bide complet
non non il ya quelqu'un qui a apprécié
je vous montre les images et si de
devinez qui c'est un avis chez vous
petit yens décolorés et cherche c'est
vrai que pendant un an il allie padam
padam on arrive devant les joueurs sont
un peu chauffé comme inspiré les
scénaristes comprend qu'elle est chez
roche ont fait c'était un naufrage
[Applaudissements]
un jour elle m'a repassé cette bande
vidéo que cette forêt de la semaine
maintenant un moment de flics comme j'ai
rarement vu dans sept d'or cette
émission c'est quoi alors cyril faites
attention à vos lancement je suis
vraiment et s'il est précis parce que je
le défie à cause de vous benjamin f a
failli faire une attaque des forces
qu'un pas en même temps ça s'appelle
bien qu'ils passent sur un ophtalmo on
parlait du téléfilm claire keim sur
l'alcoolisme et elle était ensuite sur
le plateau de julian bugier et regarder
ce qu'elle a dit clarke et que je peux
vous demander au nom j'ai arrêté
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas la même chose
vraiment alors ça en lui sa place dans
le top des danses mais c'était un peu
long vous l'état violences avaient fait
aimer d'autres choses
[Musique]
nous sommes
une sortie avec toi
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
berman acquis
je
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
il
[Musique]
je sais mais je connais bien et on
aurait eu quoi bon une bonne foi
[Applaudissements]
j'avais la tête de rat
1 oui oui mais c'est les yeux ou je te
connais tu
[Musique]
vous avez dit qu'ils seraient là soit
retenu
oui j'ai pu gâtés ah oui alors donc
c'est pas ce qui va venir ou pas je vous
dirai tout en débattant ce qu'estime
barbeau venir à ce que mathieu de robots
je vais tout vous expliquer dans un
instant rien payé plein d'autres choses
vous voulez du 28 alors j'aurais pu
mettre autre chose dans cet objet dans
ce made man serait pas été sympa pour
jean-michel à non parce que ça fait des
années qu'ils ne dit que c'est un grand
professionnel qui bossent et dossier à
fond qui connaît les invités sur le bout
des doigts
bon visiblement ce jour là ils n'avaient
pas accès à ses doigts pour sauver
agustin galiana comme tous les 15 jours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si on le prend bien et bien problème
parce que moi je veux qu'on les sait pas
non à petites astuces de chroniqueurs
maintenant alors il faut ça que c'est
très difficile de prendre la parole
quand on est autour de la table ouais
bah oui on est tellement nombreux que si
on joue pas des coudes on est patient
d'avoir la parole
en moyenne chacun le temps de placer une
phrase par thèmes abordés mais si on va
là comme isabelle morini bosc pour
glisser une deuxième grâce et n'indique
ni technique imparable
cette technique du en revanche oui c'est
très simple développer une idée et avant
d'attaquer la deuxième vous glissez un
en revanche au bien de votre phrase fait
pour faire quoi qui est une suite
logique dans tout ça alors que pas du
tout vous allez voir c'est imparable
mais monsieur madame morose la
demi-finale fait le score habituel ne
vous quitte cette saison à égalité coup
vendanges pardon n'est pas elle l est
pas et même si elle est venue parler qui
n'est pas en revanche elle est venue du
mans 18e la fois une passion freineur
mois moi honnêtement c'est fin c'est pas
le coeur de cible mais en revanche ça
tombe vraiment bien le dans ce sens
qu'une sorte de préméditation
isabelle aux non c'est pas pour défendre
france bercy impensable de faire une
émission de deux heures 23 en revanche
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire que ça va
marquer en revanche ça faut vraiment
qu'ils enlèvent ces moments je vais vous
dire il y en a un peu plus je vous mets
quand même on sait mais c'est vous qui
décidez vous voulez bah oui alors on
commence par un extrait de la venue des
harlem globe trotters les plateaux et
c'est là où on s'aperçoit qu'on a la
loose la nec partout dans le monde
ils font des paniers de tous les
conducteurs c'est vrai j'en mettais pas
une bonne heure mais connaît un moment
j'ai dit vous donnez moi spectacle c'est
ça avec ici de faire bonne figure à côté
[Musique]
mais grâce
vas-y le tir et quant à côté d'une
maison j'ai vu que j'avais vendredi vous
avez des troisièmes mi temps à marcher
quand je suis revenu aujourd'hui mais de
changer de métier c'est aussi changer de
vie et fr
[Musique]
oh
mon mari
[Musique]
on prend pas le projet capillaires a un
look anglais et un style capillaire de
pop anglaise le chanteur d'oasis au tout
ça ah ouais non jamais mort alors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour trophée du chat qui a voulu faire
comme son maître mais qui n'a pas réussi
les nommer son regard
[Musique]
donc tu abrial challenge bien encore le
tribut au magazine heat
[Musique]
c'est bien cette émission et ce rapport
entre les enfants qui interroge une
personnalité bah ça fait ressortir une
certaine forme de ces deux vérités mais
oui mais il ajouté
c'était hyper intéressant statue sur au
tableau nous sort un cutter ou tu nous
fais le pic des émissions peut lire télé
star
débutants
ses portes
[Musique]
jean-luc le voir dès 10 ans